this week we will use the concept of  momentum to analyze some more advanced  situations namely systems in which there  is a continuous flow of mass rather than  just the motion of discrete objects the  classic example of this is the thrust  due to exhaust from a rocket engine once  again we will appeal to a differential  analysis technique breaking the flow  down into a large number of small  elements analyzing one of the elements  in detail and then generalizing this is  an important example of a situation  where the point mass form of Newton's  second law of motion F equals MA is  inadequate and one must instead use the  more general form of the law F equals DP  DT or the force is equal to the time  derivative of the momentum